okay everyone we're playing this little
machine called returning the favor at
the correct one it's a cup retrieved
Mary's locket in USAF satellite station
Olivia and this was given in Abernathy
form so it just basically telling us to
go there cuz she like died and the
family won't like to lock it
mmm ok
it is these guys
oh wait real quick there's probably
fertilizer here no fertilizer
ok
yeah then nobody's place is [ __ ] home
hmm good good like that I don't know
running let's get others that let
here's play tricks on me again good up
here hey there's a person here oh I feel
bad about this guess I just like
whatever
two
I didn't know beware so there's gonna be
a little offset I see if I got a more
exciting gun oh yeah strong feel strange
security is too good
strong nite dawg brother see where them
surprise guys
someone
man come back oh please just here's the
guy over here
cry here so
no no Emma that's why
terminal only and
Trixie my legs in here [ __ ] here it's up
there wrote book though
we take ok
ok
I knew you would help any luck finding
that locket mm-hmm I've got that locket
back for you you serious that's great
news Connie's gonna be speechless
whatever the minutemen need you can
count on us good cat thank you watching
us tank